what's the story of us over the next 100
200 300
years is it a big role small
role well that's a long time if you if
you ask me let's just say the next
hundred years yeah that's okay I think
that's still tough that's still tough
but actually you know I think we're in
excellent
shape and here's the reason going back
to the beginning of our conversation you
asked me you know about power and I told
you the two principal building blocks of
Power are population size and wealth
okay and therefore you want to look
around the world and you want to look at
what you think the demographics are of
countries like
Britain uh the United
States uh
Iran uh China Russia pick your country
moving forward right what are the
demographics look like and how wealthy
of those are those countries likely to
be what you discover very quickly and is
it almost every country around the world
is
depopulating over
time right Russia's going to be much
smaller China is going to be much
smaller uh 100 years from now than both
of those countries are it's best we
could tell United
States American women are not having
lots of babies these days no question
about that but we have immigration we're
an immigrant culture you're a perfect
manifestation of that you're perfect
you're now an American that's wonderful
we need more people like you right so
when I hear Donald Trump and others
arguing that immigration is a terrible
thing this is
ridiculous immigration is what made us
great right it's when my relatives came
over in the middle of the 19th century
from Germany and Ireland right that's
fascinating like you know because there
you know there's been a huge concern
that America and other developed nations
are not having enough children but you
you just made me
realize in the long Arc of History the
United States has gotten really damn
good at integrating immigrants and you
and like helping them flourish the whole
diversity of uh that that makes up
America there's a Machinery of
integrating other
cultures yeah yeah just very quickly on
this Sam Huntington's book who are we
yeah uh which in many ways I I love that
book but it has one fundamental flaw and
a number of people told him beforehand
that that flaw existed and he didn't fix
it but Sam argues in the book that we
have large numbers of his anics in this
country and we're doing a very poor job
of integrating them into the mainstream
and they're not becoming Americans and
because many of them are concentrated in
the southwest of the United States
unlike other ethnic groups that were
spread out all over God's Little Green
Acre right we're going to have uh this
cohesive group of
Spanish-speaking Americans right who
we're going to want to break away and
the United States is no longer going to
be you know a reasonably coherent nation
state he's wrong the all the evidence is
that Hispanics are integrating into the
American
mainstream uh more quickly and more
effectively than the European econom uh
the European immigrant groups that came
starting around 1835 if you look at
immigration from Europe into the United
States leaving aside the original wasps
who came over and founded the place the
immigrants start coming in large numbers
in 1835 and we really don't shut the
door until
1924 right starting this is a crude
overview starting in 1835 and running up
till about
1885 it's mainly Germans and Irish
that's why Germans are the largest
ethnic group to ever come to the United
States and the Irish are right behind
them these are the European ethnic
groups we're talking about then starting
in
1885 uh polls Jews and Italians start
coming right uh and the Germans and
Irish keep coming and this is why Ellis
Island is opened I think it's 1893 Ellis
Island is open because Castle Garden in
New York which had handled all the
previous immigrants coming across the
pond Castle Garden couldn't handle them
all so they opened up Ellis Island
that's why somebody like me I can't find
my distant relatives records in Ellis
Island because they came through Castle
Garden right whereas lots of Jews I know
lots of Italians I know they can find
their relatives records in Ellis Island
because they came through Ellis Island
the point is you had all these
immigrants who came in roughly between
1835 in 1924 when we shut the gates
that's the only time we've ever really
shut the gates in a meaningful way right
and this is what made America great
right all these people and they made
lots of babies right so in some sense
make America great again means getting
in getting more immigrants in well we
open the gates again in ' 65 mhm closed
them in 24 open them in 65 I'm
oversimplifying the story here because
we didn't completely shut them we almost
completely shut them in 24 opened in 65
and we've had huge numbers of immigrants
flowing in these immigrants who have
been flowing in since 65 are not
Europeans they're not mainly Europeans
they're mainly Hispanics and Asians
if you look at those Hispanics and
Asians they're integrating into the
American mainstream at a much faster and
more effective clip than was the case
with those immigrants who come came in
in the 19th century and early 20th
century the Irish oh my God you know
they were treated horribly there's a
book very famous book that's been
written called when the Irish became
White just think about the title that
but there was discrimination against all
these groups right and the worst
discrimination of course was against
Chinese Americans right uh but we've
gotten much better and what we should do
moving forward is redouble our efforts
to integrate immigrants into the
American mainstream you know Hispanics
you know Asians of All Sorts because the
fact is that America is rapidly reaching
the point where it's not going to be an
allwhite country right uh I have five
children and two of my children are was
it Generation Z gen
Z gen Z is the last majority
white uh generation right subsequent
Generations are not majority white uh So
for anybody who's bothered by this I'm
not bothered by that but for any body
who is bothered by this they better get
used to it because Americans aren't
making enough babies that we can
continue to grow uh population wise in a
robust way so we need immigration and
we're an immigrant culture and this is a
great virtue it has been a great virtue
over time it should be a source of hope
not worry that's my view that's my view
and America when it works is a place
that is very attractive to immigrants
and immigrants can do very well here and
and then the real key moving forward is
in marriage right and you have a huge
amount of in marriage right somebody was
telling me not too long ago that the
highest intermarriage rates in the
United States are among Asian women
Asian-American women Asian women and
angles right and uh I say
wonderful uh and uh great
yeah no the more love love uh is the
fastest way to integrate yeah well you
don't what you want to do is you want to
eliminate difference yes right you want
to eliminate difference right it's like
you know people who say I'm an anti-s
semi right I have two grandsons who
Adolf Hitler would have thrown into a
guest chamber one of whose first name is
John and middle name is Mir shimer right
yeah this is what you want yeah right
Steve Walt's wife and his two children
would have been thrown into a gas
chamber by Adolf Hitler right this is
what you want you want intermarriage now
there are good number of people in some
of those groups especially among Jews
who don't like
intermarriage right yeah but they've
lost because I haven't looked recently
at the data uh the data among um uh for
inter marriage rates among uh basically
secular Jews but it used to be around
62% M large numbers of Jews marry goam
and they've lost because of inner
marriage inner marriage helps fight
tribalism destructive kind of tribalism
exactly calling me an
anti-semite they haven't met my
grandsons my son-in-law nieces that I a
niece that I have nephews that I have
brother-in-laws that I have Jewish right
come on and this this gives a really
nice hopeful view of America is is the
integration of different different
cultures different kinds of peoples that
is a unique property of America yes but
just to go back to where we started it
was not smooth in the beginning all
things are rough in the beginning all
things are rough in the
beginning